first of all congratulations on the
series on already getting a season two
pick up before it even debuts
how does the level of excitement around
this series feel has it sunk it in yet
do you feel like you're still in your
little bubble since it hasn't premiered
yet
yeah i i i think i mean for me i felt
like we're still in a bit of a bubble
you know it still feels like the work
that we've done is ours
and it's going to be a little bit of
like a
a birthing experience of letting our
baby out into the world so that people
can enjoy it but you know we've always
known that this day was going to come
and that would have a release date and i
think we're we're really excited it's
it's been
it's been a joy to to be here over the
last two years and and work on this show
i think um
i think it's what the world needs right
now a story like this so yeah yeah yeah
is it the same for you madeline i mean
is it something like is it just weird to
see all the excitement especially when
the show hasn't even yet aired because
you have the fan base from the books so
people are
already analyzing just the trailer
absolutely i mean you know it's it's
been a long time coming not just for us
but people that have been you know fans
of the books for years um you know and i
can you know we we feel their excitement
of this coming out uh exactly like zoe
said you know
this feels like our baby and it's we're
releasing it out into the world
really soon but you know
we've worked really hard on it and just
to finally excited to share what we've
been keeping secret i guess for the past
two years and
um
yeah it's a surreal it's a surreal
feeling isn't it yeah kind of you work
on something for a long time for two
years and then i feel like the
you know promotion of it all happens
very quickly um yeah and then you know
we're being able to have these amazing
conversations about the show with people
like yourself so um it's very exciting
well this is absolutely epic when this
project came your way what most excited
you about it was there an aspect of the
genre of the story of your specific
character that most interested you was
there one thing you sort of really keyed
in with
i think all of it
honestly it was just
i don't know this this type of role
comes around once in a lifetime you know
um
for me
personally my knees is
such a
wonderful joy to play she's so
flawed and complex and
she's just um
yeah one of
i don't know i've just had the best time
playing her so i think
it was definitely character first but
then
obviously the draw of coming to prague
and filming this this epic show was was
obviously something that was um yeah
something that i could never turn down
honestly
yeah i think just working with p you
know exactly like zoe said the stories
comes first and then once you get the
role you know you're working with
amazing amazing other actors that are
like family and rafe you're working with
the best people
in the industry and it just feels like
home um it really is the dream job
what was your audition process like how
do you go through something like this
and not get attached to the character
before you know whether you actually get
to play the character
it's
it's really difficult i think
as an actor you have to try and put in
your mind that you audition for a role
and then once you send that tape off
it's not yours you know i remember
just saying to myself as i got in the
later stages of the
uh the casting process i was like i
haven't got it until i'm on set in
costume
fully
as a grain in the two rivers um but you
know for me i
did i think two auditions uh self tapes
and then i was flown out to london
um where i met the lads and we did our
auditions and you know even getting to
that point you're like i'm so close and
it's gonna kill me if i don't get this
um and then you know i got the call that
i that i got the job and it was it all
happened very quickly and
i think my world was just i felt it
changing um for the better and it was
just
an insane period of time yeah
yeah how was how was yours yeah i i mean
i think we all had
similar casting experiences but quite
different i i'm from new zealand and i
got my audition through email and i
self-taped with my new zealand agent
back home
um shout out colin he's amazing we love
colin and alyssa
and um
yeah i got the
got i think i got the first episode
through and i was like
what is this you know
um and then
i i typed and kind of heard back
immediately and had a a zoom call with i
think it was skype back then um with an
analog i know
oh my age um i had a i had a
skype with brain
and he just helped me um get more of an
understanding of the world and the
character and and the different takes of
her because you know she's she's very
complex um and then after that i think i
had one more take to do and he got the
role and came out the crowd which is
really quite surreal i feel like i was
pinching myself for a very long time
um i didn't have the privilege of
auditioning with with
the others so it's
just
such a
a miracle that we all love each other
and we we get along because the
chemistry in particular between the the
two rivers kids is incredibly important
and
yeah we love each other to death so it's
yeah they they did their job yeah
from the perspective of a viewer it's
easy to see why you would want to play
these characters because who wouldn't
want to play in a world like this
how deep did you dive into this world
prior to shooting did you read the books
did you do some other type of research
how did you approach finding your
character and
really sort of just focusing on their
place in this huge world
yeah uh
for me when i first got cast i i bought
the book immediately and started reading
but the the um quickest kind of crash
course if you will was going to youtube
and going to read it and going to wheel
of time wiki because there's so much
information there that you know fans
have so many hot takes and opinions and
thoughts and they are the ones that have
been invested in this world for so long
so i thought what better way to really
get into
the world and into naini's head and what
people think of her then to go straight
to the wheel of time fans and i learned
a lot very quickly i learned i learned a
lot about what people don't like about
my knees and
what people do and um it was really it
was really helpful yeah
yeah absolutely and i think you know the
like zoe said the fans have been such an
amazing resource for us and you know
helping us find our characters and where
we are in the world or in the story
um you know we were flown out a month
earlier before shooting to
do our stunt rehearsals and horse riding
and movement coaching for
you know
uh
for our specific characters
style
and it was it was amazing because in in
that time we got time to protest a
process
what we were going through
not just as maddie and zoe but also our
characters and mentally prepare and
physically prepare for what was coming
coming up so it was also a great
opportunity to bond with each other
during that during that time yeah
this really is a massive world building
series with locations and sets and
costumes and language and mythology i
mean the viewers really sort of have a
lot to take in
was there anything that most helped you
get into the world and the character
when you got on set is there something
with the wardrobe or the environment or
even a prop that you always have that
helps you
i think i think costumes costumes are
incredibly helpful you know there's
something about shoes too like walking
in the characters shoes that really just
inform the way that you walk and hold
yourself
i think
i can't speak for everyone but i know it
was a moment for
for me to to walk into the two rivers
for the first time yeah i mean
it's incredible i wish everyone could
say i feel like amazon should make a
theme park out of it because you know
literally
the seat designer andre did like the
most uh he's just so talented
he built it from the ground up and and
and it was just you know surreal it's
absolutely surreal yeah i mean i
remember the first time i stepped onto
the set of the two rivers and it was
exactly
as i pictured it from the books you know
down to the finest detail and i mean
that's what's so brilliant about you
know robert jordan's writing is uh the
detail that he gives to the world
definitely the the the costume as well i
remember putting my coat on for the
first time in the belt
and i was like okay like you even figure
out how a character walks and moves um
all of those things are so important and
that's why you know
uh the collaboration that we've had with
all of our creative teams over here have
been
um so crucial with us finding out
what have you loved about your character
from day one and is there anything a
quality you've grown to appreciate the
longer you've played them that you
didn't necessarily realize when you
started
i love about my naive that she
is 100 percent naive what you get what
you see is what you get and she doesn't
care who you are i think that's really
bold and i wish i had half the
confidence that she she has i think
what's been a joy to discover with her
is how many layers that she has
underneath
and and
um just understanding that her
motivations and and
what makes her tick and why she acts the
way she she acts because i think
you know on upon first read you can see
her as something entirely different at
face value but she's
there's a lot going under there and as
an actor it's it's a joy
yeah
absolutely
yeah i think i've
really grown with gwen um
and you know she's incredibly
independent and determined
and eager to learn and ready to just get
out in the world you know she's like a
horse
out of the gates kind of thing um
and it's hard to keep up with her
sometimes but
you know she is just so determined and
just knows who she is and what she wants
and i think that's something that i've
really learned from her is just
you know
know your worth
know what you can do don't settle for
anything less than what you feel you
deserve um
they're just such strong women and you
know and they're so connected and they
really spur each other on and lift each
other up and i think that is something
that you know is a rarity
um
you know in in
film and television
and you know can be in this genre so
we're very lucky to
to
play two women that have such a strong
bond yeah
yeah i love how female driven the show
is and how so much of the strength of
the show comes from the women on it
which i think is
it is rare especially in a fantasy world
like this so i think that's really cool
yeah yeah
how bonding of an experience is it when
one of you gets to push the other view
off of a cliff i mean is that like how
do you do you
is there like an apology that happens
first like how does that whole thing
play out
you you were so apologetic you were i
think it was harder for you than it was
for me it was i mean you know it was a
bonding experience because it was
very traumatic
um
i don't know if you've had any
experience of throwing someone off a
cliff but it's not it's not
i was just amazed with how maddie
handled it i remember we did the first
take and our incredible director utah
was like that's great we got it and
maybe it was like no i can do one more i
can do it better and she so she wanted
to be thrown off again so that just
speaks to how incredible maddie is as a
person and as an actress she's just
yeah i was i was blown away but um
no i think the day was
was difficult but it definitely brought
us closer yeah no i i love you so much
and i i think the absolute world of you
um
you know and and it does it i was i when
you said it was like it's hard to push
someone off a cliff i'm like i bet but
you know there's
videos of us like hugging before doing
it and just
you were an amazing support because
obviously it was a scary thing to do and
i've felt your support the entire way
and you know as people will see it's
it's the thing that the women do is
love you know i love you you can do this
like this is your initiation
we believe in you we wouldn't do this if
you we didn't believe that you could do
this
and i did feel that from zoe from rafe
from uttar from from everyone that was
there so
um it was a really special moment yeah
characters but also for
us yeah you know 100
did you have a moment down like right
before falling into the water that you
were like yeah maybe i just won't
do it
um
i mean i
it was such a brilliant save
i was like i have to do it you know that
we we had stunt um
incredible stunt women that that
was like we could do it for you and and
that tried it at first and i was like no
i've just got to do it it's a massive
part for my character it's an initiation
moment for her and it felt like an
initiation moment for me so
it would kill me to think of somebody
else doing it and not myself so
did it feel good
and then complained about it
there's a part of you that you're like
once i decide then i'm
i mean i'm all in
yeah
did it feel different doing it the
second time does it get easier when you
do
it the second time i definitely was like
do not do bicycle legs which means it
looks like you're on a bike and your
legs kind of just go like that so i mean
because it is a stunt so
you know there is an element of
choreography to it obviously a lot of it
is real fear but
there is a way of you know falling and
moving um that
uh that is important to to get but you
know there's a lot to think about when
you're flying through here yeah yeah in
a dress as well in front of like how
many hundreds of people
getting hoisted back up um
but uh
yeah it's it's just you just adrenaline
takes over you know it's it's mental
pretty early on we see some horrific
creatures show up and slaughter a whole
bunch of people
and that's it's such an interesting
scene because it goes from celebration
and dancing to this horror and also kind
of includes magic what was it like to
shoot that whole sequence it feels like
that really sets up so much about what
the mood and tone of this series is
going to be
what's that like to do and then to see
what it looks like
it was the experience of shooting that
was like nothing i've ever
done before
i mean we shot that in september 2019 in
in prague's weather is pretty changeable
and suddenly it just dropped so we were
it was night shoots for two weeks and
not all of us on every day um
but yeah we really we really felt it you
know we were in the elements together it
was it was another i think real bonding
moment but it was also
incredible to look around and see how
much work has been put into sets
lighting the the fire the disaster
that's happening um
yeah
you felt the real desperation i think
the the individual stories are all so
poignant and and beautiful
um and then even to watch it all back it
wasn't difficult to be transported right
back into where we were you know it's
very visceral so
yeah it's i think what has translated on
screen is is really special yeah yeah
yeah
yeah i mean there's so many layers of so
many things going on in that whole
sequence it was just so impressive to
watch it's relentless yeah yeah and i
mean
we obviously know the script well but
the first time we watched it we were
shocked by what we were seeing and
obviously big
moments kind of took our breath away so
yeah i think i think it's
yeah it's pretty wonderful yeah
how much are you actually told ahead of
time going into this do you know what
like the full arc for the season is
going in or do you get bits of it as you
go
um i mean it's
broken up into episodes so we kind of
find out what our characters are going
through two episodes at a time but you
know obviously we we are aware of the
major moments that happens uh
in in the book series and our character
arcs um and you know we will have a sit
down with um
rafe and and justine gilmer who is one
of our other writers and producers who's
amazing and have a sit down with them
either at the end or the beginning of
the season and just be like this is
what's happening for your character
um and kind of map it out and
which is incredibly helpful but i think
again you know coming back to
trying to stay in the present with our
characters they all go through so much
in one episode you know there's never
kind of a dull moment
so it is really important to you know
not get ahead of ourselves
[Music]
yeah i appreciate you talking to me i
mean it's not just one episode they go
through so much just in one fight scene
so
well thank you so much i'm so looking
forward to seeing more of the series
thank you it's wonderful chatting to you
thank you